[Music]
hey welcome every damn day this is a
show where we talk about what the
internet is talking about and the
internet specifically twitter is abuzz
about this Kylie Jenner story
Forbes magazine put her on the cover
said that she was on track to be the
youngest self-made billionaire and then
dictionary.com they said the youngest
ever self-made billionaire nope that's
our own thing they said self-made means
having succeeded in life unaided no no
nobody's self-made nobody nobody's
self-made that's just not it's the day
of that it's over I'm not sure it ever
existed uh we were I were here it took
ten years and like hundreds maybe
thousands of people for me to do this
and that's just how well you think about
though your connection and how you live
your life and like you have students you
know teachers and all kinds of like
that so I think that the whole idea of a
self-made person is ridiculous so you
know so people are dictionary.com was
correct secure a dictionary dad can so
be clear dictionary commas not throwing
shade at Kylie dictionary.com is
throwing shade at Forbes dictionary.com
defines throw shade as insult criticize
or disrespect a person or thing in an
indirect artful manner I'm sorry did you
make yourself a car I made it yeah I
found an extra car for the discussion
just I have cards and I do a very good
job reading oh okay I think it's unfair
because Kylie Jenner is like touching a
bunch of heat about this and people are
like upset as if she were proclaiming
that she's self-made what she didn't do
but she did build like this huge makeup
company put on a blazer for the car
they told her what it was and she's like
oh yeah of course
Forbes cover sure yeah exactly but it's
not like she's out there like Drake like
he was like had the song he's like it's
all me and there's eight riders on that
song it's not like she's out he's doing
that she's just on the car putting your
face on the cover you're fully
supporting what they're saying about you
do you think I don't know a magazine was
like I want you to be in a bikini on the
cover for hot bodies I'd be like I
understand this is false and I don't
want to people do do some a stuff we
just don't hear about they don't make a
billion they make like thirty million
because that's all you're gonna for
you're gonna get a little small loan in
the bank she didn't get along from the
bank she started off with like millions
out the gate yeah of course she's not in
the kitchen sitting there just me goes
and she's not making like stuffy eyes in
the sink or in a bathtub if she had a
bathtub full of ice stuff I would be
like no Chad brown Facebook oh I want
Chris to be the new like PR person for
[Laughter]
ruining the seat right just jazz up
those late lips you know me that I would
she's not something me she was me here's
a factory probably in a basement but to
be fair anyone who's reading forbes is
probably a pretentious out and has money
so it's like it's not like a very
hardworking person who's working every
day they don't have time to stop and
read a magazine do you know what i mean
like no one's really
hello i'm jordan and once a week i take
a little more psychedelics than usual
and write in my journal these are my
thoughts when you're about to fall
asleep it's never not funny to say to a
partner a friend
hey wake me up when September ends this
also works when a hotel concierge asks
if you want to wake up call
this has been
[Music]
ladies today's topic what makes us what
climatic or daddy makes us her dog Wow
how clean what gets me wet wiener dogs
in Wiener costumes winners for the price
of one okay hello and you can eat when
you can cuddle so that is the chair so
we get another chair can we fly in a new
chair yawn new chair no can I put a
blanket down hug thank you so you'll see
it's so what about a hair dry it can we
blow it out alright
no you know what gets me wetting when
you get pizza and the cheese comes up
from all the other pizza bites having
you at home wetter than the box oh so
she they're juicy extra you know it gets
me wedding a magic show that's so well
done that by the end you're like was
that magic down and lay me out to dry Oh
rapid fire what makes us what Nordstrom
clothing with Mortimer crisis climate
change documentaries I'm like Al Gore
deeper okay true Paola when you eat corn
on the cob and your teeth come out clean
Oh getting glitters in May oh wow oh wow
okay don't touch me too sensitive
I gotta take a nap so I didn't catch
your your ladies names no great not
seeing grace okay
do you use Kylie's cosmetics my lips the
size of our lips normally oh yeah people
say did someone cut your lips anyway
that's what people say do ya yes this is
an improvement
yeah people say that we are the Kiley's
of our neighborhood watch okay okay Wow
well this is really something we'll see
you tomorrow and every day
[Music]
you